I was thinking a lot about monsters to
them and we were having a debate in the
writers room about your favorite monster
you know I think is weird about monsters
your favorite monster is often the one
that scares you the most
that's isn't that kind of weird that's
the opposite of your favorite anything
else you know I mean nobody's ever like
you know who my favorite uncle is the
one with the chapped lips and the
dandruff whoa uncle Barry he just gave
me those willies so good work let's talk
about a little bit who's the scariest
monster I can feel because they're in
the zeitgeist some of you might be
thinking zombie I'm gonna say right now
not a scary monster I'm not frightened
by zombies always staggering around
staggering just drunks bunch of drunks
after last call that's what you got as a
monster oh jeez it's not frightening
they look like drugs with their dish of
old clothing and unexplained injuries
remember oh I got this mummys also not
scary for the same reason cuz mommies
are really just Egyptian zombies just
some dusty old guy wandering aimlessly
that's not scary slow like your
grandfather when he gets loose from his
bed at the home
[Applause]
I'm just saying when I see a mummy I'm
not afraid I want to go up to him give
him a cup of pudding and ask him if he
knows where he is then they're vampires
sort of scary I guess if you're afraid
of being seduced they're always inviting
you up to their weird mansions for
dinner
that's scary like oh he's so hospitable
it's not scary what's the scariest thing
that can happen with a vampire he bites
you and he lived forever in his gorgeous
mansion isn't that where all what we're
all trying to do live forever
in a mansion and vampires they wear
capes everybody knows that a vampire
loves wearing a cape gaudy jewelry big
rings 1970s medallions not scary that's
just a guy from Jersey before the spray
champ loaded the Machine with white well
time to put on my typical Jersey Cape
Jersey Cape vampires don't even turn
into scary animals think about it they
turn into bats bats aren't scary they're
icky that's not an emotion you're trying
to evoke as a monster icky someone's
goal to be like not a good monster
werewolf
that's a scary monster that Wolfman is
just so terrifying it's a man who turns
into a wolf that's it and that's enough
there's a guy then a wolf
then you dead
it's simple it's honest it's clean
they're like The Ramones of monsters and
the only way you can kill a Wolfman is
with a silver bullet so basically if you
could give me a four and a half month
headstart like I'm gonna attack you in
the spring
I'm not finding a silver bullet but as
bad as the Wolfman scares me you can't
hold a candle to the alien I think the
alien is the scariest monster scares the
absolute out of me with their
futuristic technology and mind-reading
abilities with their giant heads I don't
care if it is ET giant head with a
Sistine Chapel finger to kill that tan
long fingered bastard before he reads my
mind and the scariest thing about aliens
may be real yeah deal with that may be
real and no weakness
think about it werewolf you got the
Silver Bullet vampire wooden stake
aliens lube up it's happening
[Applause]
[Music]